nobody doesn't love the Multiverse but
whether we can gain access from one
Universe within the Multiverse to
another
that's in the whole that's a whole other
story I know Rick and Morty do it and
and and and doctor strange does it but
by the way the Multiverse is a natural
consequence of our understanding of what
happened in the early universe that
bubbles of universes just sort of pop
out and we just happen to be one of them
so it's an idea embraced by most modern
astrophysicists
and it's kind of a cool notion too
that maybe there's another universe
with someone just like you in it it's
just a little different
or a lot different or a universe that
doesn't have you at all
get over it